[Music]
20:16 was definitely the year of driving
autonomously from Tesla's to trucks
Robo drivers were everywhere this year
Google's autonomous fleet quietly hit 2
million miles by now these cars really
know their way around Mountain View
Tesla dropped new software updates for
autopilot its self-driving feature that
idiots quickly abused for a few seconds
of YouTube fame and while the death of a
Florida driver using Tesla's autopilot
raised questions about how the
technology should be applied Elon Musk
has already announced a grand plan to
take his company's self-driving skills
beyond the highway he promised that
sometime next year
Tesla will take itself entirely from Los
Angeles to New York City and right now
these cars can at least get out of super
tight parking spaces which is actually
pretty sweet this year uber made a lot
of its drivers very nervous
the ride-hailing service started testing
its own autonomous cars in Pittsburgh
and gave its customers of you of how
self-driving tech will figure into their
lives our test ride was mostly smooth
and a human driver has to be on hand
just in case all hell breaks loose at
least for now lots of things besides
cars are getting themselves around now
firefighting helicopters drones that
shoot sick footage army trucks that haul
supplies and drones that explore our
ocean floors but the best thing to drive
itself a beer hauling big rig auto the
self-driving truck company that uber
bought this year ran 50 thousand cans of
Budweiser from one end of Colorado to
the other while the driver hung out in a
back seat
the company says humans will still be
needed to get the trucks on and off the
highways and you know to buy and drink
all that beer in a safe and responsible
manner of course so cheers to our sober
designated robot chauffeurs we call
Shotgun
[Music]